hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play psychosis
I'm already disturbed because there's
one freaky looking clown on the left and
then there's a terrifying little girl on
the right so I don't know what I'm
getting myself into but it looks
diabolical and I don't like it at all
don't look play why don't we collect all
the keys to escape what sounds familiar
let's see what we're getting ourselves
into I wonder when the first jump scares
gonna happen oh boy I don't like this at
all but anyway hey look a door nothing
like looping door sounds to get the
atmosphere all settled in nice fire
effects I can see the budget was just
astronomical in this game that's from
the Texas Chainsaw Massacre there's a
big ol machete why can't I take that
with me I would like that what is that
it's a typewriter that says raccoon on
it there's some barrels there is no key
here and lo ah
Oh balls
okay yeah they need to definitely fix
the sound in this game but it would whoa
that son of [ __ ]
oh good I'm going outside I'm sure that
wandering into a cornfield is a great
idea
reminds me of the level of left4dead I
always liked that one with a farmhouse I
always like the original left4dead okay
other than being loud I'm just assuming
that there was nothing they actually
chasing me which was my first assumption
I still don't like that damn looping gah
ah ah okay which way do I go this way
cuz it seems like mother [ __ ] Jason
is anything actually gonna kill me just
kill Ian and the torment I wonder when
the first jump scares gonna happen you
guys need to take some relaxation
therapy classes get some scented candles
take a nice herbal bath smoke some weed
I don't care do something relax I want
your walking cane what walking cane you
mean my sort of yet yes